les alliés de l'OTAN réunis autour de la
table déterminée à renforcer la défense
entière Etienne de l'Ukraine
assis côte à côte le ministre ukrainien
de la défense et son homologue américain
Lloyd Austin qui a dénoncé les dernières
attaques russes sur plusieurs villes
ukrainiennes
nous allons tout faire et le plus
rapidement possible pour donner les
moyens aux forces ukrainiennes de se
défendre et protéger les populations
c'est très très important pour nous
depuis le début de la guerre l'OTAN
n'envoie pas de troupes en Ukraine pour
ne pas provoquer un conflit direct avec
la Russie en revanche les Alliés
fournissent chacun de leur côté de
nombreuses armes et munitions à Kiev
véhicules blindés obusier drone système
de défense aérienne ou antichard mais
selon le chef de l'OTAN les Ukrainiens
ont besoin de plus
au terme de la réunion plusieurs États
membres ont annoncé fournir de nouvelles
armes à l'Ukraine les États-Unis et
l'Allemagne notamment la France va
suivre la même dynamique est-ce qu'on va
livrer ça ça ne dépend de personne
d'autre que de nous ce sont des radars
des systèmes et des missiles pour les
protéger justement de ces attaques et
donc oui tout à fait donc ça on a déjà
fait on va l'intensifier donc des radars
et des systèmes avec des missiles
anti-aériens en particulier pour les
protéger des attaques de drone et des
attaques de missiles et donc ça c'est ce
que nous allons faire dans les
prochaines semaines Emmanuel Macron a
également confirmé l'envoi de six canons
d'artillerie César en plus des 18 déjà
livrés ainsi que 20 véhicules blindés
bastions
le matériel militaire livré à l'Ukraine
par les Alliés représente plusieurs
milliards d'euros et permettent à Kiev
de faire la différence sur le champ de
bataille
et